who is Shazam what makes him unique and
in an era with so many superhero movies
why did it take so long to bring him to
the big screen let's take a look at the
world's mightiest mortal with all the
stuff you need to know before you see
Shazam a secret identity is at the core
of nearly every superhero some like
spider-man keep it secret to protect
their loved ones for Shazam it's more
because when he's not being a superhero
he's literally a child comics can be
weird unbeknownst to the DC universe at
large Shazam is actually Billy Batson
played in the movie by Asher Angel after
a fateful brush with mystical forces
Billy gains the ability to transform
into Shazam the world's mightiest mortal
decades before Stanley Watts the comic
landscape with the idea that kids could
relate to teenage heroes like Peter
Parker Billy Batson was the first
mainstream kid protagonist on the comic
book scene that might have been part of
the reason that his stories sold better
than any other characters in the 1940s
including Superman at one point moving
over 2 million copies per month and it
makes sense what kid wouldn't want to
transform into an unstoppable magical
superhero with a single magic word Billy
Batson becomes Shazam a lightning
powered hero played in the movie by
Zachary Levi exactly what that means
however it usually depends on who's
writing the comic well he always turns
into a pile of altruistic super muscle
with an a-plus jawline
Shazam himself has been a number of
different things sometimes like in the
movie he be chains Billy's childlike
mind in a super-powered adult body in
other iterations he's a completely
separate entity who magically changes
places with a kid either way he's got a
pretty impressive set of superpowers the
magic word Shazam is actually an
acrostic listing the names of the
legendary figures from whom he draws his
considerable powers he has the wisdom of
Solomon the strength of Hercules the
courage of Achilles the vaguely defined
power of Zeus a stamina of Atlas and the
fantastic speed of mercury which is
usually used to explain how he can fly
Luca and obi-wan how he had a Dumbledore
and chasm has Shazam yes Shazam's mentor
is also called Shazam and yeah it's
awkward working with someone who has the
same name a chair with at least
superhero exploits a sort of a
specialized field you have to play the
cards you're dealt she's handled you're
probably going to hear the word Shazam a
lot
this movie so you might as well get used
to it now in the movie Shazam Billy
receives the power to turn into a hero
named as Shazam by saying the magic word
Shazam thanks to an ancient wizard who
has helpfully also named Shazam the
wizard is a mystical being who guards
the world from his magical cave but you
know how it goes a couple of thousand
years on the job when you start feeling
ready to clock out in the comics he
summons Billy to be his new champion
granting him the aforementioned
abilities because bud said is a
genuinely decent dude with a pure heart
in the original story the wizard is
immediately and permanently squashed by
a rock after handing out the super
powers but in true obi-wan fashion he
occasionally returns as a wise ghost to
help guide Billy in the movie he'll be
played by Jamin hoon soo who eagle-eyed
viewers will notice has already showed
up in guardians of the galaxy
Aquaman and Captain Marvel that last
ones are pretty interesting notes but
we'll come back to that in a second
being a superhero is a stressful job
so it's important for a crime fighter to
have a place they can call their own
somewhere they can relax talk to the
ghosts of their dad who lives in a
crystal or have their Butler help them
build a rocket car you know the stuff we
come elite to glare yes if you have a
location like on a cliff like a castle
ask type thing you're looking some water
Shazam secret hideout has traditionally
been the place where everything started
for him the rock of eternity like so
much of Shazam story it's changed over
the years but generally the facts are
these it's a magic lair it's distinctly
rocky and it has a rad throne in many
versions the rock of eternity sits in an
otherworldly realm outside of space and
time joined up to our world by mystical
means at the Magic subway train has
summoned Billy Batson to inherit his
objectively awesome destiny it's also
used as a prison for magically bound
enemies of the Shazam company of heroes
including the simple scepter to known as
the seven deadly enemies of man the
first time Billy Batson was summoned to
the rock of eternity the wizard Shazam
has some pretty unsettling furniture a
difficult to ignore collection of giant
statues depicting humanity's worst vices
surprisingly enough they weren't just
statues they were stone prisons built to
contain the demonic personas of each of
the seven deadly sins originally
referred to as the seven deadly enemies
of man
they include pride Envy greed hatred
laziness selfishness and injustice what
the comics code lightens up a little
they swap the enemies of man from their
name of sins and switched out
selfishness and injustice for gluttony
and the definitely not Code approved
lust
needless to say they've occasionally
escaped their stone presence always of
the intention of wreaking havoc and
general bad behavior it's been confirmed
by director David F Sundberg that they
will be appearing on the big screen in
Shazam and it's easy to suspect that
we'll see them as more than just a set
of statues since his introduction in
1941 Freddie Freeman has been Billy's
right-hand man as a comic book character
with an alliterative name he was pretty
much locked into getting powers at some
points and sure enough hit becomes his
um sidekick by the end of his first
appearance like Billy himself Freddy was
another down-on-his-luck orphaned kid
with a disability that required him to
have a crutch to walk you look at me and
you're like why so dark your disabled
foster kid you've got it all in the
Golden Age comics Freddy's leg and spine
were casualties of a fight between
Captain Marvel and a villain named cup
did not say Captain Marvel feeling two
heaping scoops of super heroic guilt
shared his powers with Friday giving him
the ability to transform into the
ever-so-slightly condescendingly named
Captain Marvel jr. the new 52 reboot of
the character was a little more rascally
a pickpocket with just a hint of jerk
he's one of Billy's foster siblings the
two become close and Freddy eventually
gets the super-powered adult persona of
his own he's played in Shazam by Jack
Dillon Glaser familiar to many viewers
thanks to his appearance as Eddie in
2017 it's dr. thaddeus bodog sivana has
been the conniving arch-nemesis - Shazam
since day one a moral and polar opposite
to the hero he's a small stooped mad
scientist with his eyes perpetually
obscured behind thick round glasses he
sneers he jeers he brings good guys to
tears his frequent early appearances
were almost always accompanied by a new
contraption designed to foil his nemesis
who he delighted in calling the big red
cheese hey that was a pretty sick burn
back in 1941 like most comic book
villains a sivanna took a darker turn in
modern stories with a much more tragic
origin story after losing his family he
tries everything from science to magic
to bring them back a mystical accident
grants him a magic sensing eye the use
of which slowly decays his body Mark
Strong who plays Savannah and Shazam
already has a superhero movie pedigree
he appeared in kick
and played Sinestro in DC's kind of
regretable Green Lantern if dr. sivana
is Shazam's lex luthor black adam is as
General Zod see the Shazam from Shazam
wasn't the wizard Shazam Shazam in other
words there was another guy who got
powers from the wizard back in ancient
times this previous Shazam was named
Adam originally from Egypt and sometimes
from the fictional nation of Kahndaq but
always from several thousand years ago
the wizard granted Adam powers are
thinking that Adam was pure of heart
but sadly power corrupts and super power
corrupts super bleh instead of a hero he
became black Adam a super villain
overlord on his bad days and a giant
jerk of an antihero on the few good ones
there haven't been any official
announcements with regard to Shazam but
Dwayne the rock Johnson has been signed
on to play Black Adam for years did we
see him in this movie well no one sure
yeah but you should really know better
than to leave before the credits finish
if you want to find out when DC
relaunched a universe in 2011 as a new
52 all of their flagship characters got
a modern reimagining it wasn't the first
time that Shazam had been updated but it
was definitely the reboot that changed
in the most that's how Billy Batson got
a family drawing his rebooted Justice
League he was taken in by Victor and
rows of Vasquez foster parents who had
grown up in the system along for the
ride were Billy's new foster siblings
Freddy Freeman
Darla Dudley Eugene choy Mary Brumfield
and Pedro Pena drawing his climactic
fight with Black Adam Billy learned that
he could share his abilities with his
family and transformed all of his
brothers and sisters into new lightning
crackling super-powered versions of
themselves Victor and Rosa are set to
appear in the movie and while Freddy's
got in the most screen time in the
trailers the Shazam siblings are along
for the ride to DC and Warner Brothers
are definitely shooting for a franchise
with this movie so don't be too
surprised if you see them power up by
the time the credits roll to superhero
movies always throw in a few Easter eggs
for die-hard fans and Shazam's long
history as plenty of weird characters
who might show up in the movie just in
case they decide to toss in some odd
balls here's who to watch out for
obviously Freddy Freeman is showing up
in the film and sharp-eyed fans already
know that Mary Bromfield has connection
to Billie that goes back a little bit
further than the other kids but then you
had sorts of superheroes like Uncle
Marvel he was just a chunky old dude
dressed
in tights and hung out with a group of
children it was a different time
one of the more in drawing bits of
extra-strength weirdness came in the
form of Torquay Tornai when he was
introduced in the 40s
Torquay Toni was a literal tiger who
learned how to talk wear clothes and
walk on his hind legs because he wanted
to be like people he was great there's a
more modern version of the Shazam story
that recast Toni has a stuffed animal
which would give the movie an easy way
to throw him in for fans as for whether
the stuffed tiger could come to life and
start eating bad guys the odds are
pretty slim but hey you never know
if saying your own name to transform
into a physical ideal seems a little
self-centered even for a superhero take
a little comfort in the fact that Shazam
didn't start out that way when he was
introduced in 1939 if the character was
called Captain Marvel which technically
makes Shazam the second Captain Marvel
movie of 2019 here's where things get
loopy when Fawcett comics put out their
new comic book about Captain Marvel the
Shazam one back in 1940 DC noticed a
number of similarities to the character
that debuted in 1938 he was a big dark
haired dude in a cape who could leap
tall buildings and had strength occurred
only be called super his costume had a
familiar design to her he was even
throwing a car on the cover of his first
issue which felt a little familiar to
the company that have introduced
Superman in action comics issue 1 DC
sued for copyright infringement leading
to a messy disputes that ended with
Forster out of business and Captain
Marvel going out of print for about two
decades in those intervening 20 years a
rival company had appeared called Marvel
Comics since the copyrights on the
Captain Marvel name at elapsed these new
guys had snatched it up for their own
character who purely by coincidence
we're sure also changed places with a
younger alter ego after years of using
Shazam as a title for comics and
confusingly calling the hero Captain
Marvel in the stories themselves
DC would wind up officially changing the
character's name to Shazam meanwhile
Marvel would just keep making more and
more heroes called Captain Marvel
eventually beating the distinguished
competition to the screen of their
latest version by about a month seems
like the speed of mercury only takes you
so far check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite superhero
movies
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]